Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 25th, 2013. How you doing?
How are you happy thanksgiving.
Eat some Turkey and
some stuffing and Gravy
v.
Then he'd saw Paul.
Why?
I love Thanksgiving. I really
do. But you know, I'm actually a,
I'm leaving the country of
going to be an ex patriot.
Now I'm leaving the country. Um,
the Wednesday before thanksgiving,
I didn't even realize that this is going
to be the first thanksgiving I ever
spend, you know, outside of the country.
I'm actually going to be over in
Italy like, like, like one of the,
some of the army guys back in the day in
World War II sitting over there when no
moon itch your eye like a big pizza pie.
Shoot him in the face.
Um, getting ready for my big European
tour over there. Have you buddy?
You know, I didn't realize when
we went to book this thing,
how fucking cold it was going to
be in Scandinavia in December.
And I just did some, uh, some
interviews there for the,
a Norwegian journal or
the fucking Swedish, uh,
a periodical, whatever the fuck I, whoever
I was talking to over there. And um,
they told me they were laughing
that I was coming over there like,
why are you coming over here now?
Which is never a good sign. You know,
when the people of the nation are not ope
we like or not welcoming you with open
arms, they're immediately going like,
yeah, you sure you want to do this?
I guess the sun goes down
at three in the afternoon.
I can't believe it's like,
is it that far fucking north?
And I'm starting to think about
it. I'm like, wait a minute.
If he goes straight across from
Massachusetts where I grew up,
where do you end up? Mediterranean
Sea. The south of Spain.
I okay. I don't even fucking know. And
then I'm thinking like, wait a minute,
they've wired a minute, their way,
the fuck up there. They're like,
Yukon territory's did that high up, you
know, cause you look at a fucking map,
it's flat. You spin a globe, you can't
see it. It's, it's around the corner.
Where is it? Where is, you know,
am I supposed to take a strength?
I didn't fucking know.
So evidently it's going to,
the sun's going to go down at three,
then it's going to be cold as hell.
I don't give a shit.
It's still going to be a good time,
you know, break up my party. Um,
yeah.
You know what's funny though is I
talked to this person in Iceland,
the radio show, and they said, okay,
before we start this, I got to do the, uh,
I got, uh, you know, they were, we were
recording it for the radio and he goes,
all right, before I, uh, I asked you
the questions, I just have to do a
intro, so I'm like, this, this,
and this is always cool because they
speak in their native tongue and then they
go right back to you.
And I had never heard the Icelandic
language and it's fucking cool as hell.
You know what it sounds like. Remember
when they would play lyrics backwards,
that devil shit on, on metal
records. That's what it sounded like.
And he's like, okay, I'm going to
do the intro of a Ba. I can't do,
I can't even do the accent.
Then he just goes,
Rashi up to the opposite cause
I'm about to gift build births.
It's riskier option and offering
more stand up comedy or a lot barrel.
So you're coming to our
country, it's like, oh my God,
I opt these fucking people going to be
bilingual because there's no way I could
ever make that.
You know?
There's certain languages that I
feel like I could make like Spanish.
I know if I could just find some beautiful
Spanish woman to teach me Mexican,
Latino,
whatever the fuck I'm supposed to say.
If you just come over here with your
Brown titties hanging out of your fucking
beautiful white blouse, you know,
I could learn the damn language.
All right? If I could get some French
woman dress up, like one of those horror,
I would have it down.
The problem is as I sit here with this
Rosetta stone and I'm talking to a
fucking computer,
where is the motivation?
The second I walk away from the computer,
I can immediately speak English
and to do anything I want.
I can get food, I go to Africa, I go to
Asia, they can do whatever I want. Um,
why don't I just think of that
weird girl and a breakfast club? Um,
I didn't know if that was
the proper quote. Anyways,
back to what the fuck I was talking about.
So like the motivation isn't there.
So what I think I'm going to do this
next time I try Rosetta stone to learn
Spanish,
French,
whatever the fuck I'm trying is I'm
just going to have beautiful women
like pictures of them on the wall.
Even then what's second to do?
You don't what they should have. They
should just start like, you know,
like they have like those,
those late at night talk to some hottie
and they just show these ridiculously
hot women. They're like, yeah, hey,
for some reason nobody's buying
me a bunch of stuff tonight.
I'm just sitting here with my panties on.
Why don't you call me up and talk to
me? You visited back fat. Fuck right.
Any of you, you know what isn't
true, but you want to believe it.
So this might be a good business and I
don't want to start a fucking business.
All right. I have no, so
feel free to steal this idea.
What you do is you hire a bunch of
hotties to Skype with people to teach them
the language of the nation.
Nah,
that would work because the might have
times that they would click to talk to
somebody and all they would see is
just some dick getting fucking stroked.
That would just be really traumatic
for those beautiful women.
And why would you want to that?
You know, if they were nice enough,
if they were nice enough to like take
time from being hot to teach somebody at
different language,
they're probably at the person so
they shouldn't be subjected to that.
All those other horse that are just
walking around being hot for hot sake for
the sake of being hot and getting
a free Jello shot. You know, I,
I wouldn't have a problem with them
having some video dick like shook in the
face. Does that make sense? I'm
unbelievably fucking jet lagged.
Everybody's speaking of smart people.
I did it,
a college gig at this theater and a,
and I literally flew
out and came right back.
So I don't even know the name of it.
I have no idea.
It's the second time I've been there
and I want to shoot a special there.
The crowd was fucking awesome. They're
okay. I showed you my respect. But um,
I went there because me and version went
to the Harvard Yale game at the Yale
Bowl, the original bowl in
the United States of America.
This is the one that started all of it.
The reason why there is the rose
bowl that I go to every fucking year,
uh, is because of the Yale Bowl. And
we went there and I got to tell you,
we saw what sports look like without
the use of any sort of steroids.
Versie was fucking hilarious. He was
going to bill. I'm not even joking.
I feel that if I went to this
school and I played for Yale,
like I could not only
make the football team,
I could like dominate,
like I could stand out and I
understood why he felt that way.
I'm not saying he's right,
but to sit in the stands and for the
first time in my life be watching college
football and seeing people that
are kind of the same size as you,
I know the way fucking faster and
all that type of thing. But um,
it was unbelievable.
Yale versus Harvard.
Harvard kicked the shit out of him and uh,
I got tell you like it was,
it was really cool just being
around that many smart people,
just like some 20 year old fat kid walking
through the crowd wearing like a bow
tie, like not like a clip
on like you tight yourself.
Like he knows how to do it.
It's just immediately,
it's like how fucking smart is that guy?
Like who knows how,
who fucking knows how to do that?
I'll take two.
Smart people in plantation owners are
the only ones who know how to do that
fucking bow tie.
Right?
And then there was some really
good looking women there
and they will, they will,
you know, that was just, that's a really
turn on to seek women that good looking,
you know, I mean, they're
actually going to Harvard.
They just not walking around being hot,
getting free shit.
They're actually doing something with
your life. That's really a turnoff.
Can imagine banging a girl like that.
Just being on top of it. Like, Oh God,
she's so smart.
Yeah.
Ah, she has all the answers.
Um, I know this is ridiculous.
So the Yale Bowl, everybody,
in case you're wondering,
the Yale Bowl is a football stadium
in gun wave in new haven, Connecticut.
I'm on the border of West Haven,
Yadda, Yadda, Yadda, Yadda.
It was constructed in
broke ground in 1913.
All right, cost them 750 grand,
17.5 million in today's dollars.
Uh, that was the hundred 30th
meeting between Yale and Harvard.
And I was just sitting there
thinking like George Bush.
George W used to get fucking shit faced
back when he was still a good shit
drinking, you know, he
used to get hammered here.
Hilary fucking Blue Bill
Clinton under the bleaches,
right?
Those, those two families, they're
the worst. I don't mind his dad,
but fucking Georgie Jr and the Clintons,
they're just the fucking worst.
But anyways, um, basically
ground was broken in 1913
and it was the first bowl shaped stadium
in the country in provided inspiration
for the design, the design
of such stadiums as the Los
Angeles Memorial Coliseum,
the Rose Bowl and Michigan stadium.
This was the one that started at all.
This is the daddy to the
granddaddy of them all. All right.
This is Zeus to all the Athenas
and Mercurys and all that shit.
Did I jump between Greek and Roman
gods? I don't give a fuck. All right,
you God damn egg head. Once you go tie a
bow tie again today, nobody gives a fuck.
Um, so we went there and through first
he was so fucking fun. First of all,
he killed on the show.
And then
we was staying at this hotel
and before the show, uh,
we were hanging and, uh, in my hotel
room, you will watch an Lsu play in, uh,
the Aggies. And I was great
to see Lsu went, you know,
all the disappointing losses this year.
And uh,
when you looked out the window,
you could see Yale's campus and I
was joking with Paul and I was going,
look at it, Paul. I go, it's so close. And
then I pointed to my brain and I'm like,
yet so far away and I'm laughing.
And in first he's such like a
fucking competitive psycho. He says,
going to fuck that to fuck these
fucking people. You, he's like,
you think we couldn't get in to
the school? I'm like, yeah, yeah,
I don't think we didn't Paul. You know,
you're going to go into fantasy land.
What happened is we both went to high
school and we tried and we didn't get in.
So yeah, there's that. This isn't even
like a debate at this point. We didn't.
And now we're coming back here like a
couple of fucking dance and monkeys to
entertain these people.
All right.
And he, he wouldn't, he wouldn't leave
it alone. He just kept going like, dude,
fuck that. If I had a
better upbringing, you know,
if I had like people who like made me
focus on academics and if I be gap,
Paul. Yeah. If you're not the result of,
of Morons fucking right.
That's too harsh.
Um, I feel like I'm the same
way. All right. Jesus Christ.
So just attacked his parents.
That's that. You know,
that's the last thing I want to do on this
podcast. But first he's sitting there.
He was, what was not joking
saying that he could be,
he could make it,
he could've went to Yale.
And that's why I love that guy is
I just sit there and look at go,
there's no fucking way
he's, yeah, we could do it.
There's no fucking forsee
if you're listening to this,
there is no fucking way.
If your parents made you read books
every God, like there's no fucker.
We've said enough dumb shit to me.
The foundation of you.
It's just not there. The same as
me, Paul. Okay. It's, it's built on.
It's built on sand.
Um,
now had either one of our parents gone
there and then we were part of a legacy
or whatever the fuck they call
it. We could go, I could go there.
I could go to Yale the way
George W went there. You know,
get their, have that fucking look
on my face. Just getting shit faced.
Everybody loving me. He's a complete fuck
up. He's, he has no business being here,
but he got the, he bought the
keg. Right. I'd be that guy.
I don't fucking know. Either way. We
went to the game and uh, it was great.
It was really like a, it was sort of pure.
There was nothing riding on the game.
There's no reason to play football at
Yale and Harvard other than you love
playing football. And then also the fact
that, you know, they're all really smart.
That was something really
fascinating about it. Like that guy,
look at that guy out there,
he gets geometry and he just went
over the middle and took that hit.
That's just fucking amazing to me.
Just multitalented so I've got all
kinds of respect. I've got to tell you,
I think Harvard was on the juice. So
BECU or they have some sort of, I dunno,
lock on draft picks because they see,
they've seem to be a definite,
a sizable difference between the
athletes on Harvard side versus a Yale.
And I didn't no to root for.
I liked the ales colors spot.
Harvard's for math that [inaudible].
All right, I'm done with this shit.
I'm all right back to the
fucking podcast. So, oh,
I have an announcement to make everybody
after threatening forever that there
would be podcast tee shirts, ladies
and Gentlemen, Gentlemen, gentlemen,
boys and girls of all sizes, sizes, sizes,
the podcast t shirts are here,
t shirt and fo.
They are available as of right now,
Monday morning they come in
gray and white sizes, small,
medium
extra luggage and double extra large
tee shirts at 20 bucks in the United
States. 25 for foreigners. Uh,
Dvds were also 20 bucks, 25 for a
international, you can buy them together.
And safe t shirt and Combo is 30 bucks,
US 35 international. And I gotta tell
you, man, that makes a great gift.
As I say every year.
It's a great fucking gift just for
somebody that you don't give a shit about,
but you got to get them. You
got to get himself right.
Get them a DVD. Here you go.
Go Fuck yourself laughing up. Oh
right. Who doesn't like a tee shirt?
All right, these are those in amp. Now
what is it? Oh, not Abercrombie and Fitch.
Who's the guy who takes the
creepy pictures of teenagers?
It begins with an a,
you know, you know the deal, you
know the fuck they are. Ah, fuck.
Whatever.
They're nice and soft.
This is really bad to say after he
saying he takes pictures of teenagers,
he has those creepy things.
It's not Calvin Klein. He's
like the new Calvin Klein.
You know what I'm saying? They're fucking
great tee shirts. All right. And um,
this is also good thing too. You know,
brother, father, anything for guys,
a God tee shirt and a DVD, my moron
comedy, they're going to love it.
It's a perfect thing. The lovely
Da. Everybody coming into the room.
You got it. I got to
sign white here. Jesus.
And she comes in here with
a goddamn blank check.
It tells me I just have to sign it.
Do you understand the faith I'm
putting in you right now? You know,
it'd be hilarious if you just cleaned me
out right now and I never saw you again,
Huh? I would never do that. You don't.
You sound like you sound like Sharon
Stone right now in that basic instinct at
La Brea. Crazy, right? A fucking
something. Some. All right. See you. Um,
you have a nice day with my money.
I'm chunk fucking with you. Come here.
That's make always make taking the
joke one one fucking step too far.
Why did she have to say that?
Now people aren't gonna think they're
not your fucking saint for being with me.
All right, so there you go. Tee Shirt
and folk. You got it. It's up there.
Paula. Days are calming. If you order
now, all right, there's no fucking way.
You're not going to get it
before Christmas. I guarantee it.
And if you don't get it before Christmas,
I will show up at your Christmas party
in 2018 doing a tap dance with the
fucking two to one.
That's a guarantee.
I'm really betting that you're
not going to remember that.
It's going to fucking get there.
It's all I'm saying and no,
I'm not doing your Christmas party,
right? Don't be so God damn selfish.
I got to humiliate myself.
Don't I do that every week when I read
the advertising? Speaking of which,
Eh, I think it's time for a little bit of
advertising. Everybody. Here we go, um,
in danger right now of not making
the cut on the tour here. All right,
now let's try to make me make it easier.
We'll say that par for the course
is three. Fuck up these reeds.
All right? All I want to do was make
part and I want to be one under.
I'm going to come into the clubhouse
with a smile on my face. All right,
here we go. Dollar Shave Club,
everyone for a couple of bucks a month.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing
quality razors right to your door.
Not only does it save you a ton of cash,
it saves you from trudge into the
drugstore for a pack of blades. All right?
I always get stuck behind that old
couple that wants to buy ice cream and
develop their photos as they sit.
They're sharing a pair of loafer loafers,
one on stroke against me,
dammit,
but now with dollar shave club for
just a couple of bucks a month,
amazing quality razor blades are delivered
right to your door. That's right.
No more wasting time and no more
getting hit up for 20 bucks.
Every time you go to buy razors.
Everybody here is getting that dollar
shave club blades and you should too.
Everybody here meaning me
and here's the genius idea.
Try replacing your old shaving
cream with doctor cavities.
Easy shave butter from dollar
shave club.com trust me,
your face will thank you later.
Don't waste time at the drug store
behind the lady paying and Penny's.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward slash
[inaudible] or go to [inaudible] dot
com and click on the
dollar shave club banner.
Keep your stress level low and your
bank account Balance High Shave time,
shave money, go to dollar shave
club.com forward slash. Burr.
That was one under, I only had
one. I was 200 for that one.
Oh my God. Look what's back
everybody. Look what's back.
Just in time for the holiday season.
Doobie Doobie do in school to lead,
but get a fucking man Greg and throw
it at you. Daddy's head, man. Great.
Everybody. Bill Birdman, man.
Great copy for Christmas 2013 I don't
think that that was part supposed to be
part of the read here.
All right, now it starts.
That was just a couple of practice swings
off the tee. All right, this holiday.
Can I have a Mulligan this holiday
season? Think the man. Great.
What is the man great you
ask or maybe you didn't ask,
maybe I'm putting words in your mouth
cause I know what's good for you.
There are 100% made in America
cast iron grilling grades that are
revolutionizing the way people grill named
one of 2012 best grilling accessories
by men's health magazine.
You liked that grilling men's health.
Is there enough Dick's in that story
for you that you know this is a good
product. They're the perfect gift for
this holiday season. Click on the man,
great banner on Bill [inaudible] Dot
Com for their 1999 holiday special.
You can thank you father for bringing
you into the world for less than $20 and
every time he goes to eat a steak,
he's going to call you up. You know?
Thank you son. God bless you for
1999 you can have that conversation.
Remember each Monday morning podcast
or to comes with a heavy duty grilling
brush. Again, that's the man.
Great Grill enhancement system.
Order today@billboard.com or you,
my friend are an asshole. All
right, one more Hulu plus.
You've probably tried
hulu.com now with Hulu plus,
you can watch your favorite shows anytime,
any where Hulu plus lets
you watch thousands of hit
TV shows and a selection of
a claim.
Movies on your television or on the go
with your smart phone or tablet and it
all streams in HD for the best
viewing experience with Hulu.
Plus you can watch your favorite current
TV shows like Saturday night live
community and family guy.
Do you know what?
It's actually just called Saturday
night because they had how Howard Cosell
actually hosted a Saturday night
live or something like that,
so they weren't allowed to say it.
That's why they say live from New York.
It's Saturday night. Just to give you
that little tidbit of information,
I learned that the other day reading
an actual book about Howard Cosell.
Why would I read about it? Other
things, because I'm a moron. Anyways,
back to Hulu plus,
you can always check out exclusive
content including Hulu originals like the
author [inaudible] starring Snl,
Seth Meyers or s ends,
Seth Meyers and moon boy starring
Chris O'Dowd from bridesmaids.
Hulu plus also offers a great selection
of a claim films fully seven 99 a month.
You can stream as many TV shows and
movies as you want wherever you want.
Right now you can try Hulu
plus free for two weeks.
When you go to Hulu plus.com/bill
that's a special offer for my listeners.
Make sure you use the Hulu plus.com/bill
so you get an extended free trial and
they know that we sent you go to Hulu
plus.com/bill now are click the Hulu plus
banner on the podcast page
at [inaudible] dot com damn.
And I was doing great and it came up the
18th fucking fairway and I shanked it
the goddamn woods. All right. Back
to the podcast here. All right.
Very uneventful week. I
feel everybody. So, uh,
considering there's not a lot
going on in the world of politics,
what should we talk about? Oh, I don't
know. Hey, let's talk about sports.
Anybody Watch any sports this
weekend where you're, where you're,
where you're watching things that involve
sports. Was there sports watching?
Um, all right. First things
first I have to address the, uh,
the no call pass interference thing
last week and the panthers game, um,
that was obviously a Monday night game,
so I didn't comment on it.
I didn't have a problem with it.
I thought it was a good no call.
I didn't like that they threw the
flag and then picked it up. But
how's Gronk going to make
it fucking play on a pass?
It's not even going to get to them.
It's not like the guy who interfered
with them or held them, caught the ball.
It was another guy who undercut the route
and I just feel like the rules in the
NFL right now, our tips so
heavily in favor of the authentic,
it's nice every once in a while
to see the defense get a break,
even if it goes against my fucking
team. Okay. Classic examples.
If you watched the giants
cowboys game early in that game,
I think the cowboys were up
seven enough and at that point,
okay,
they forced a fumble.
They recovered it in a way from the play.
There was a flag with a cornerback
barely grazed this wide receiver and a
negated. The cowboys, you know, turnover.
The defense made a play cost to turnover.
Once again,
made a play cause to fucking
turnover. It's in this, this new,
okay.
The new rules. I mean I
can't complain. They are,
the rules negates that and in stops them
from having a short field and possibly
going up 14 to nothing or 21 nothing.
I can't remember what.
So I did not have a problem with it.
Good for the panthers and I actually
tweeted that I didn't have a problem with
it and all got all these
fucking condescending. Yeah.
Like responses to it like oh it's good
to see a levelheaded patriots fan.
It's good to see an
impartial patriots fan.
It's good to see a smart patriots fan.
What?
Cause I fucking agree with you and
your team. You Selfish Asshole,
you know right there.
That's when you know,
like you don't have a true friend is
when they just like you because you agree
with them. And I would, I am,
I would be willing to bet a most of my
fucking whatever my shillings here that
those people who compliment me or
not impartial and had the call gone.
If the exact same fucking
thing happened to their, uh,
their receiver and they lost the game,
they would be bitch moaning
and complaining and saying
how Tom Brady runs the
league and all that fucking shit.
All right.
So before you sit there and try and
pat me on the head and say that I am
impartial and I'm a smart Patriots Fan,
that's not a fucking compliment.
All right? You're a cunt. All right?
As long as I agree with you and your
team and I don't agree with my team in it
causes you to have a victory, then,
then I'm smart. Go Fuck Yourself. Um,
and with that, we get to a,
yesterday, yesterday's games,
the New York football giants lost.
And I know a lot of people think
that I hate the giants because, uh,
they beat the Patriots two times
in a row in bowls. I don't,
not only do I not hate the giants, I love
the giants. I love that organization.
I've liked them for fucking ever all
the way back to Harry Cas and Brad van
pelt, Beasley Reese. I've
been watching them forever.
I've always liked the giants.
I like the uniforms. I like the,
the defenses. I just liked to,
okay.
There's nothing better
than haven't like doing,
they had Lawrence Taylor and
Harry Carson and you know,
I was like Wilbur Marshall.
I was always like big linebacker.
Like I'd like the bears.
I like defenses and that type of thing.
So I don't hate the giants.
What I hate is listening to Paul Versey
talking about how he called something
because he doesn't just
say it for that weekend,
he'll say it for the next seven years.
So the reason why I wanted to see the
giants lose is because I don't want to
listen to versus talking to me.
Like he's Nostradamus if that's
how you pronounce that guy's name.
Um,
so that's all.
And what kills me too is that
division is so bad that they're still,
they're still not out of it. There
are only two games out of first place,
three from going all the way up front,
which should be insurmountable
after 10 fucking games.
But with that division, it
isn't. It isn't. All right.
I don't know who shot. I don't know.
He's not waiting on what are the,
are they for, are they foreign?
Seven. Oh, so it's 11 games. Oh yeah.
That pretty much fucked. Um, but I was,
I got to tell you the back of my head,
I was kind of hoping that they were going
to make it into the playoffs because
playoffs, because I have a feeling
just the way the giants are.
They,
they would beat
Seattle in Seattle and another bunch of
people would probably think that I hate
the Seattle Seahawks because I
did that whole, you know, the,
we are the loudest song and I always make
fun of Pete Carroll. I don't hate him.
I don't give a fuck about the
Seahawks one way or the other.
I think the loudest crowd thing is silly
and it's something that you focus on
when you don't have any championship
banners to look at. And I stand by that,
but that doesn't mean I want you to lose.
But Pete Carroll,
it's just funny watching that guy loose,
you know, watching a guy who goes,
oh
woo,
something good happens. And he's
totally proved himself as a coach.
She's a great fucking coach.
He's a great college coach.
He knows how to build up the program
illegally and right before the,
the all the shit hits the
fan to walk away from it.
And I don't begrudge them for doing that
because that's how the game's played.
The same way I don't begrudge lance for,
for doing what the fuck he did
when everyone else was doing it.
I don't regret any of that.
And everybody who gives the Patriot shit
for the spygate thing is living in this
fantasy fucking land that
your teams do not cheat.
I'm reading this great book right now
on, uh, uh, I don't have the title of it.
I'll get it for you next week.
Lie had gave me the book, uh,
somewhat the last headbangers
or something like that.
It's like basically back when you just
played with concussions and that type of
shit, the level of cheating
that was going on. First of all,
they didn't even test for steroids I
think until like 1988 and football.
And if you read about the Oakland Raiders,
who still to this day bitch
about the fucking tuck rule, um,
does shit they were doing in the 70s.
Do Dino,
like they used to have like their pads,
they used to soak them in water because
it would make them hard and it was
almost like having like a cast on and
they would just club people in the head
and other teams knew
that they were doing it.
So during the pregames and the warm ups,
they would wear the soft ones and they'd
have their hard ones under the bench.
And it wasn't nine Zillion fucking TV
cameras and people in the crowd all having
TV cameras with this smart phones.
So when the game started,
they would put the other pads on and they
would just clock people fucking head.
These guys were claiming they were
taking horse tranquilizers and they were
doing the dosage for a fucking 1500,
1200 pound fucking horse.
Um, they were out of their minds,
hopped up on everything in the plant.
So people have cheated all day long.
And the greatest thing about cheating
is watching people who don't cheat,
discover that there's cheating
and to just watch them as adults,
once again discovered that there's no
Santa Claus and seeing their bottom lip
quiver. I just, for the life of
me, the reason why it's funny,
it's not cause I can don't cheating,
it's just that
I just don't,
I don't fucking get,
I like how many times you've got to get
fucked over to realize that how human
beings are, you know, I'm a piece of shit,
right?
Why wouldn't a football team where
there's a zillion dollars at stake and,
and your legacy and your, your,
your spot in the all time list.
I'm not saying everybody's going to cheat,
but I just get this fucking shot.
Look off your face. Like when Oj got
acquitted, oh my God. That millionaire,
the guy who had the money enough to be
innocent gets declared in this. Yes.
All right. Am I fucking, I
might like preaching right now.
I should shut the fuck up. Oh, and
then also, what was I gonna say?
Uh, how unreal was that? But
that Patriots Broncos game,
I guess it's unreal if you're on the fuck
at winning side or if he didn't give a
shit who won or not. Um, unreal.
I watched that game flying.
I was on Virgin Airlines,
who by the way,
they have this five minute music video
for is great is that airline is when you
get on that plane,
rather than have them announce like
this is how he put on a seatbelt and the
mask, which usually takes live
human beings like a minute,
they made like a five minute video
that tries to have all the like people
dancing and singing and then auto tuned
voices.
And I gotta tell you,
it is one of the most horrific things
I've ever heard and it's played at such a
volume. I had my fingers in my ears and
I was humming and I could still hear it.
I heard it on the way out and
the weight on the way back,
I just gave into it and I just watched it.
And um,
I don't,
you don't,
you don't really annoys the shit out of
me is people who dance with an attitude.
Look on their face like they think
that they're fucking amazing like it.
I'm not saying that I don't
respect the art of dancing,
but what is with that look on your face.
You know like you're fucking Gronk.
Koski and he just dragged fucking the
entire secondary over the goal line.
What are you doing? What? Cause
you did a little Shim Sham. Huh?
Cause you're shaking your left shoulder
while your right toes doing something
else.
Like now you have this look on your face
like line up across
in your reading the defense.
What is the,
what is with that fucking look people
have on their faces when they dance night,
I think did Fred Astaire
had that look on his face?
When you're dancing there's only one
look you should have on your face and it
should convey roughly. Ooh. All right.
Stop looking at me like you're
going to take my wallet.
Okay.
I th I just don't fucking under.
So it's five minutes of that combined
with like auto tune and that fucking robot
dancing that I,
I just don't with this fucking
look of attitude. And then rapping,
they got some little girl
fucking rapping,
like sounded like dice
when he makes fun of women.
Okay.
About how to put a seatbelt on and it
goes on for like five minutes as you sit
underneath these aquarium,
TJ's lights.
Okay.
The same ones that they
have at the w hotel. Um,
other than that it's great because you
get to just sit there and watch TV.
So anyways, when I got through the
whole fucking a put on your seat,
that's it. Rock, whatever
the fuck they was singing.
Oh, just wasn't fucking end. So, um,
I actually,
I was watching the Patriot,
I watch all the giants game and then I
want went into the winter to the Patriots
game right before we
were about to make a 24,
21 got off the plane and
somehow it was already 24, 21.
And I went by the bar and I score,
saw a score to make it 28,
24, sorry, 24, 21 and then 28, 24.
And um,
okay.
It was in state and then the whole way
back from the airport versus he was
texting me the updates. And right as
I got home, I saw the replay of the,
uh,
of the punt
with a guy inadvertently touched it
because he didn't hear Welker tell him to
get out of the way. But uh,
what a fucking game. And um,
yet another reason why
you don't leave early,
but I don't think that that
was a definitive example
of what Brady and Manny can
do. Cause I thought the elements
played such a fucking role in the game.
But I will say this Brady
is 10 and four and 14.
Matchups against Peyton manning.
So I am done with that argument.
All right. If you want manning, go
ahead. You can, you can have them.
I will take Brady any day,
all day.
You know, Brady doesn't even
have that look on his face.
Neither this Peyton manning
that these fucking dancers have.
Is it trying to tell me how
to put on a fucking seat belt?
Did people who liked dance too,
they just get sick of getting beat up.
So now they feel like they have to take
it on and now they have to have a game
face.
Um,
I was just watching it like,
when did Kevin Garnett start dancing?
I don't understand. Oh, that's not Kevin
Garnett. That's just somebody dancing. Um,
I'm so exhausted from watching that
whole fucking game and traveling around.
I don't know what to say. I'm not going
to try to rub anybody's nose in anything.
It was at the end of the day,
an unbelievable win and just a regular
season fucking victory. And, uh,
but it was, um, it definitely,
if you watched that game and you still
leave games earlier, you're not a sport.
You leave the game early and
not a fucking sports fan.
I just was watching people,
Clara,
I understood because it was fucking
freezing and you're down 24. Nothing.
I understand if you're down 24,
nothing at the half and it's
fucking like absolutely freezing,
disgusting. And you with your little
boy or your girl and they're cold,
they want to go back to the car. I
get that. All right? But if you're a,
and you're standing there in the fucking
stands for the love of God, all right?
If the offensive lineman can be out
there and short sleeve shirts, you know,
you can't tough it out and you mighty
Mac with your fucking mittens and they
leave or they watched one of the
historical comebacks in New England sports
title town.
It's just an unbelievable run.
Every time you think you've seen the last
great thing that's going to happen and
then it's going to go back to the way
it was, another great thing happened.
So I feel very blessed as a sports
fan so far. They go, they go,
great fucking game.
And this is the thing too.
I don't think as much
as that was a big wind,
that doesn't mean shit
when the playoffs come.
Cause we're going to have to go into
Denver and at the end of the day to use
that overly used expression,
Denver could come back and beat us in
January and then who gives a fuck that we
beat them in in November despite the fact
that it was unbelievable victory. Um,
I mean,
shit that happened with the jets.
We absolutely raped the jets and December
and then a month later we lost to them
at home. So who gives a fuck? Um,
they're both great quarterbacks and the
both great teams and who gives a fuck?
It was an amazing God damn game. I can't
believe he came back and won it. And A,
I'm done arguing the Brady manning thing.
I think the numbers speak for themselves
as far as the way I look at the numbers.
And,
uh,
I think they both played each other
enough times with all different kinds of
teams. Loaded teams, patched together.
Teams like our fucking defense last night.
I'm so fucking sick of them two talking
about how many injuries we have on
defense and then they go and like,
they absolutely just,
just ran right through the guts of that
Patriots' defense. It's like, Oh yeah,
the one word yet where the
guts were already ripped out.
There's no guts left in it. Well,
there are, cause we won the game.
I'm not saying that people are out there,
but do we start started four
rookies yesterday. I it just,
you got to have a guy as good as
fucking no, Sean running the ball. Yeah,
he's going to rack up some fucking yards,
although over 200 is an excusable.
So whatever. All right, let's
uh, let's get on to the,
uh, the questions this week.
See, I think I handled
that really well. Help you.
I don't rub your fucking noses
in it unless you jets fans.
Um, all right. Response to
last podcast or Yankee fence,
respond to the last podcast.
Uh,
this is in response to the item
mentioned on your last podcast,
the brother that had the 16 year old
sister who was dating a 22 year old.
Okay? All capital
letters. This guy writes,
the brother needs to stay out of it.
All right?
So for those of you who
didn't listen last week,
there was a guy who is 16 year old sister
was dating this 22 year old dude and
he was questioning,
do I knock this guy the fuck out?
Do I say something to my
sister? Do I somehow get my
parents to wake the fuck up?
What do I do? All right, I gave my
advice in. This guy is saying this,
he seems like he's speaking
from experience or this
woman, whoever wrote this,
the brother needs to stay out of it.
I met with a lady,
I met my now husband when
I was 15 and he was 20.
Well, you little fast tramp.
You couldn't even drive a car.
How did you even meet a 20 year old, Huh?
Oh, you standing on the street corner?
Eh?
I'm sure you're a nice person.
Sorry. Um, you were 15 and he was 20.
Did your plane crashed?
And he was stuck on an island and it
was like that blue lagoon or some shit.
He said we started dating just after I
turned 16 and we got married when I was
20 and he was 25 we have now been
happily married almost 25 years.
Oh, that's a nice story. It may not
work out this way for this guy's sister,
but it also might work out to and ended
up being a stronger relationship than
any relationship this guy might have.
It's none of the brothers
business stay out of it. Okay.
Hmm.
Miss, I respect your point of view
and what happened to you. All right.
Well let me ask you this.
Yeah.
If you have a daughter and she turns 16
and some 22 year old guy starts sniffing
around the house, are you going to
just sit there and be like, well,
my husband was 20 and I was 15 you know,
I gotta be honest with you.
The difference between 20 and 15,
a 15 year old is a fucking,
I can't quite say a child,
but there was a massive age difference.
Forget about the legality of it.
And most states other than Mississippi,
I'm
sorry, I'm fucking with
you guys. Um, 22 to 16.
I mean,
you're talking about somebody who's in
the middle of high school dating somebody
who's graduated college. Ah, that,
I dunno. I Dunno about that. All right, I
look, can you at least understand
why this guy, is that upset
and have you ever watched to catch a
predator? I mean that there's not like,
there's not like evidently a
zillion fucking creeps out there.
How many seasons have to catch a
predator? They did. They do. I mean,
you would think like the amount of people
out there that are going online trying
to meet underage women. You
wouldn't think that. I mean,
I would like to thank
that there's maybe 40 people doing that,
but there isn't.
There's a bunch,
hundreds of thousands of fucking
creeps out there doing that shit.
So this guy is supposed to stay out of
it and roll the dice that maybe this guy
is a good guy like your husband. Well,
all I can say is I hope that you're right.
You've had,
fortunately you've had more this in this
than I have because I would not want to
have experience in any shape or form in
this and I don't think my family would,
um, stay out of it. There would
be major fucking problems.
There'll be major fucking problems. There
would be. It's like, Dude, you're 22.
What the fuck is wrong with you? How
did you even meet my sister? You know,
how are you, how are you meeting 16 year
olds? You fucking creep. I, you know what?
Maybe I'm ignorant here. Why
don't you write back again?
I want to hear the story.
How you guys met,
you know,
was he teaching you how to
add and subtract? Sorry.
The jokes are just too easy.
All right.
Thanksgiving Day special Billy Crocker.
There's a new one.
Betty Crocker. Billy Crocker. I
liked that and I like to cook. Oh,
that's a good one.
Love your intensity when it comes to
bringing something to the table on
Thanksgiving. Absolutely.
No Pun intended. It's,
it's really a no brainer.
Get good at making something and get
to a point where your automatic oh,
he's talking about, yeah, like I
was talking about a few weeks ago,
when Thanksgiving comes around,
you got to have that dish that you just
fucking can make and you throw down and
you take it to another level.
All right?
Everybody else should be doing
the same thing. And then the end,
that's the Thanksgiving meal.
Um, so this guy goes, yeah,
you should get a dish downs where
your automatic. How hard can it be?
A you'll, you'll never
been x. You'll never been.
You've never been expected to step out of
your skillset. If you're baking breads,
no one will ever expect you to
bring the cranberry sauce. Uh,
what should go to this year?
What's Nias specialty?
What's my Goto this year? How
about the whole fucking meal? Dude,
I'll tell you right now. You guys
stick. I'm a fucking a one trick pony.
I can make you a Turkey dinner.
Was stuffing mashed potatoes.
My gravy game is getting better.
I got to work on my gravy game and
I know that's crucial. All right.
But my fucking, ah, my mashed potatoes,
not a fucking lumping
them all right enough.
Bato to make you slag off the chair. Um,
as they say in New Orleans, that's bad.
New Orleans accent. I admitted
my stuffing. Go Fuck Yourself.
All right dude.
You know,
you don't understand the recipes that
I have access to all of my recipes.
Start with melt a stick of butter and
a third, a cup of Chris. Go in a pan.
Okay. So, you know, it's
delicious. Um, yeah,
my stuffing.
MMM.
I don't my mashed potatoes or the shit,
but knee is African American,
so she likes more sweet potato. So
I don't, I don't think they, uh,
that side respects mashed potatoes
the way they should. Okay.
I feel like my potato, my, my,
my United colors of Benetton,
whatever the fuck it is. Respectful
for sweet potatoes and mash potatoes,
I think I'm a little more mature.
Okay.
Then the lovely Nia. Um,
what's Nice specialty, uh,
Nias she's just great at everything.
She's one of those people that I,
I'll be out in the kitchen like,
dude, what the fuck? I'm starving.
But she'd be like, what do you
[inaudible] she comes out there and like,
she knows she's got a couple of
things on her arms and I dunno,
I'm eating spaghetti or I
don't know what the fuck.
I mean she somehow just throws it all
together or make some ridiculous omelet.
Okay.
Um, she's actually a true cook.
I'm a little more robotic. Um, mmm.
Okay.
I think I'm going to become a,
uh, a great cook or a better cook.
The way I became a better comedian where
at first I was a joke writer and I was
trapped in my act and then I learned
how to Improv and she's kind of just
watching her.
She kinda as she cooked,
she's tasting it and doing all
that type of stuff where I just,
they said to leave it at 58 minutes, it's
been 15 minutes and I take it out. Um,
pies, I kind of got the whole thing
do from start to finish. My, uh,
my appetizer game is terrible.
In fact,
I don't even know if I know how to
make one. I have no idea, but do what?
I can make a pie from fucking scratch.
Okay?
Yeah.
I can look at you and tell you what all
your fucking problems are as I'm making
the pie crust and not even look down
once I can just feel the texture.
You know what I'm saying? That's how
many fucking Pi's I've made. All right,
and I'll take debt
pie someday and I'll bring it to
your fucking house. All right,
and I'll take a whole hunk of it just in,
I'll just shove it.
Write down your throat and these nothing
that you're going to be able to say
other than thank you for that experience.
All right.
As of shaking up the can of
whipped cream to give you a facial.
You know what's funny about this?
My attitude like cooking is the same
as like those dancers with this stupid
fucking looks on their faces.
Take that fucking look off the Goddamn.
Unless you just dunked on somebody.
Okay.
Unless you have a loaded fucking
pistol pointed at my face.
You take that fucking look
off of your God Damn Grill.
Is She a fucking moon walking across
the stage? Like I'm in awe of you.
I'm not saying it's not a,
not a great skill to have,
but what you're doing versus the look,
the look on your face is so far down
the fucking street compared to what the
fuck you doin.
What is that?
Yeah.
All the way back to those Janet
Jackson videos. Hi Miss you much.
And she'd have this fucking look in her
face as she's putting her fingers in and
she's hopping around. And it was amazing.
Visually. It was amazing to look at.
But why do you have that
fucking look on your face?
Why are you all dressed in these army
uniforms? Like you're fighting in a war?
All right. Get back to the way
it was. All right, everybody.
Five, six, seven, eight Chanel. You know,
I just realized that Shamiel
shemozzle Lavar Yiddish words.
I never knew what it was.
I thought it was Jewish guys that ran
the beer company that they worked for.
And I know I'm not
pronouncing them correct. Uh,
Shamiel is a kind of guy I guess spills
a drink and is Shamar Shemas I can't say
unless I sing the song.
Shamiel schmozzle a shemozzle
schmozzle is the guy spills it on.
How funny is that? There'd be tell you
guys so much. I love Yiddish words.
I actually just looked up a bunch
because I wanted to learn some more cause
they're fucking hilarious and
they're fun to say. And uh,
I really liked Jewish humor, but uh,
I actually looked up and it was like,
I knew already knew 90% of them.
There was so many that I was
using and I didn't even realize,
did I already talk about this or did I
start to talk about I don't give a fuck
the holiday week.
You guys got a short week.
How psyched to you I'll fucking greatest.
This is the work week that we
were supposed to have. Remember a,
remember the Jetson's be, Oh God,
these three day work weeks. A murder.
All right. The Yiddish handbook.
40 words you should know.
MMM.
All right.
There's just so many that I use shuts
spa nerve extreme arrogance five.
And using that Roth.
I thought that man,
he had like no Hotspurs to get up and
go shuts Ba is, oh, that's funny. Like,
shut the fuck up. I don't need your
arrogance. A glitch is a Yiddish word.
Kibitz a Klutz Kosher,
obviously.
MMM.
Notch is to nibble.
Schlep.
I never know.
Sh there is
Sheila meal is a clumsy person.
So similar to a Klutz,
the kind of person who always
spills his suit, his soup.
I know I'm butchering the,
sorry, Jewish people. Uh,
sh Sheila Mazal is someone who with
constant bad luck when the Shamiel Sheila
meal spills his soup. He probably
spills it on the sh Sheila Mazal
that's fucking,
I'm sorry.
I know I fucking
Schmaltzy Shmooze schmuck.
We all use these words,
shtick. I had no idea.
I had no fucking idea that these were
all these leaders will all Yiddish words.
You know, it's a fucking great
Yiddish word too, for your Dick.
Schmeichel that fucking perfect.
That just sounds like what it is.
You can just hear the trouble you're going
to get into with it. Ah, what happened?
Am I fucking shoot Michael did it
again. Goddammit. Um, all right,
here we go. Let's, let's move
on here. Oh, you know what?
I gotta do some more advertising so I
don't read these too late in the podcast
so they don't fucking bitch,
Moan and complain. All right,
here we go. Here we go.
All, there's only one more for this week.
Look at this short week short list of
advertisers. All right, he voice everybody
the, you know, the holidays are coming.
The holiday season,
Scooby dooby Doo and business.
And as a business owner, you know
what that means? Crickets, right?
Who's coming into your business is
they're hanging up all the holiday cheer.
Face it. The next couple of months
are the calm before the storm.
Now's the time to do something
that would drastically,
dramatically help your
2014 he voice Jesus.
What did I eat?
I can't even get this out.
He voices his simple technology that
helps you make more money. Yeah,
that people to simple technology that's
going to make you more money if you're
not paying attention.
Now you,
my friend are a jerk off with he
voice toll free or local numbers,
call routing tools.
And a professional dial by name directory.
Your business will look like a million
bucks and with the voice if you could,
if you can't take a call,
they will transcribe the voicemail
and email it directly to you.
You'll never be caught off guard again.
He voice has been saving companies
thousands of dollars every month,
making them more efficient and more
productive. There is no quicker,
easy way to transform your business for
2014 and with the voice you can try it
before you buy it.
What more do they have to do right now?
You can get a free 30 day trial to eat
voice when you go to [inaudible] dot com
slash bill burr or go to.com
and click on the voice banner.
That's [inaudible] dot com slash bill
burr bill burr.com and click on the voice
banner.
There you go.
Now's the time to take charge of your
business and prepare for a productive 2014
all right, I gave you the
links, eve voice.com/bill burr,
Bill burr.com and click on the voice
banner for your Free 30 Day trial. They,
you go, that's the deal. That's
the advertising for this week.
And now we're back to the
back to the lettuce. Um,
holiday friend Billy. Oh, uh,
I've been seeing this girl
for about a month and a half.
Handful of dinners and some sex.
Very nice.
You like to eat? You'd like to
fuck. Who doesn't like doing that?
This guy's over here like, Hey, what
do you want from me? She's super cool,
but I'm emotionally unavailable.
Oh,
you son of a get a bad father
bed. Parents. What happened?
Huh?
You get thrown in a burlap sack and
beaten with a read like fucking a Dr Evil.
What happened to you?
Um,
he said I got too much stuff going
on with work to be thinking about a
relationship. However, I'm
enjoying this casual situation.
She seems to be happy as
well. Oh Jesus, dude, you're
going to break her heart, man.
Okay.
Women don't look at the Sh
this shit the way we do.
She seems happy as well because she's
probably thinking it's going somewhere is
what I'm guessing. And then one day can be
like, yeah, you know, I'm not feeling it.
And then she's going to start crying
and it'd be like, what the fuck?
I thought we were just fucking,
and then she,
that's all you thought this.
Okay.
We went, oh, we got ice cream.
Do you know anyone? It's like,
just pictures, Seinfeld crying.
That's what you're going to hear.
Um,
however, I'm enjoying the casual
situations. She seems to be happy as well.
So what do I,
what do I get her for Christmas?
That doesn't make it look like I've
made room for her toothbrush. Dude,
you shouldn't get her
anything for Christmas.
Don't get her fucking thing for Christmas.
Don't fuck her until after Christmas.
Why are you filling up her heart with
hope? Don't do this. I've done this.
You're going to hurt her. He goes, I
was thinking about some small things,
a book and maybe a sweatshirt from
this place on the beach that she likes.
Oh well isn't that thoughtful
to get her a pack of Fig Newtons,
like share a package of those.
Let her know where you stand. He said, ps,
the last gift I bought a
girl was a few years back.
We've been dating for three
years and she cheated on me. Oh,
we had been dating for three
years and she cheated on me.
I found out over thanksgiving, and when
it came time to give Christmas presents,
I handed her a frame with a poem.
The first part of the poem was super
sweet. She was getting emotional.
Then she got to the last line,
which red after these words,
your heart's feel heated,
but stead,
I'm going to piece because bitch,
you cheated.
Holy Shit.
Wait a minute.
Is that a true story? I don't even care
if you made it up. You have to write back.
I want to hear what happened.
What the fuck did she say?
Jesus Christ, Dude. That's like,
yeah,
I'd expect like, oh, that's like,
okay,
that's really deep, man. That's really
clever. That's really intelligent.
That's a kind of thing a woman would do.
You know?
We're usually just knees and
elbows, like what? You know,
just start screaming at them
because thing, you know,
you were in a full Nelson by some other
fucking jerk off dragging you away and
you're in the right. That's really,
uh, that's really amazing. Um, I would,
I would say I would say this,
uh,
oh wait, this is my podcast
person texting me right now,
trying to call me right now
and he's getting on a plane.
So that's why this podcast is late. All
right? And also I had to do this radio.
Took a fuck yourselves, right?
It's the holiday week. Come
sit in here. My slippers.
What are your thoughts? Um,
my thoughts are as you're,
you're really going to hurt this woman
cause I feel like you haven't had a
conversation with her. You said, you said,
however,
I'm enjoying this casual situation and
you said she seems to be happy as well.
So that indicates to me that
you guys haven't talked,
sat down and talk this out.
And I can guarantee you if this
woman is any of that with thing,
like the women that I've dated,
it's already too late.
All right. Um, she might
be happy thinking like,
Oh wow, he's taking it slow.
He's really getting to know me.
You know, he got me a sweatshirt from
this place on the beach that I like.
He's paying attention to me.
He is noticing things about me.
You know what it is do you are actually,
you're actually a relationship guy,
but this other woman ruined you and you
got to get that hate out of your heart
or the defensiveness audio heart before
you should be messing around with
somebody like that. Right. Right.
Now what you should be doing?
It's just going out and just,
I dunno,
working on yourself while
yeah.
Fucking everything that moves or,
or maybe not.
Okay.
It shouldn't be going like don't hurt
this. I don't know what's going on.
Cause this is still very vague, but don't
hurt this woman because that last one,
her, yeah, I've made that mistake.
It's a bad, it's bad dude. And I,
and I know I'm not judging you for being
in that situation because you're a guy
and you shouldn't understand them.
But now that I understand them
a little bit more, uh, you know,
um,
you're headed for a fucking,
if I had to guess you're headed for
a rough or shortly after Christmas,
you know when she goes,
you want to meet my parents that I could
wear this sweatshirt that you got me
from the place in the beach that you like,
you know,
and she'll bring that up right after she
just blew you and your Saturn and you'd
be like,
yea no,
I was going to watch the holiday bowl
instead with some buddies of mine get to
watch the outback steakhouse.
Steak House fucking bull.
Okay.
And then she'd be like, well,
wait a minute. Why? Why?
Oh, I, I don't understand.
And then he'd be like,
and then you're going to be starting
to sense like, well, what do you mean?
You understand?
I just invited you to meet
my parents and you're like,
you don't want to meet them.
Huh?
I a little, a little offended. I mean,
these, these are, these are my parents.
I sounds kind of awesome.
Joe Starts hanging down.
He in understand what she's saying.
I said, Ha, okay. And you're like,
and then she starts crying.
And then if you're like,
most guys should get mad
because you're uncomfortable.
All you got to fucking cried out.
Say something.
Oh yeah.
Fucking rolls into a snow drift. I'm
telling you, dude, you, you don't,
you don't want to go down this
road. I, I got a bad feeling.
Okay,
I've got a bad feeling about this one man.
Um,
just make sure that she's enjoying
this the same way you are,
dude.
Who wouldn't like to be with the super
cool girl that you don't have to fucking
be emotionally involved with
WHO's coming over and banging you?
Now let me tell you something,
dude, this is not 100% on you,
so don't feel guilty because she also
hasn't sat down and had the conversation.
Okay?
Maybe she has her baggage.
Maybe she sat down and said that to
some other guy and it scared her away.
She said, okay, now to
south, did I bring up,
hey is this guy said
[inaudible] have a lot of data.
Um, coffee shop girl,
dear illiterate cunt.
I'm not illiterate.
I just not good at reading out loud.
It doesn't make me a literate.
I can still read the words.
Okay.
Did that, did that just sound like
somebody illiterates I'm smart.
Fredo all right. I'm a
young guy. Oh my God.
Some 21 year old kid just
called me an illiterate cunt.
And you know what?
I got to take that on the chin.
I got to sit here at my locker
at the end of the reading game.
I take full responsibility for that loss.
I've got no one to blame, but myself,
I'm a young guy,
21 and I have kind of,
and I kind of have a thing for a chick
who works at my local coffee shop.
Please tell me she's not 16. I don't
want to read another one of these. Uh,
the idea of chatting her up while
she's working always seems weird to me,
mainly because I know she has to listen.
Just give me some quick tips so I
don't come off as a Weirdo. Love the,
and thanks dude. Are you fucking kidding
me? This is the perfect situation.
All right. Oh, she works
at the local coffee shop.
Oh, I thought you worked with
her. Fuck, that's the perfect,
that's the perfect situation.
If you work with somebody that
you're into as far as you know,
being able to talk to him,
it's not weird at all. And uh,
you can make them laugh and that type
of thing, then they get into you.
But then the bad thing is,
is then you start fucking somebody you're
working with and you've got a pretty
good chance that you're not gonna make
the playoffs with that one, you know?
And you're going to have to rebuilt and
it's going to be ugly and you're going
to lose your fan base.
And the fan base will be other chicks
that worked that you probably should have
been fucking instead of that
whore. But anyways. All right,
so you're walking into this coffee shop
and there's a girl there working there
that you like and you don't want to
start because it's going to seem weird.
All right.
Well,
what's weird about that is to try to do
it in line is you're really dealing with
a, a, a short period. It's like a vine.
You're going to try to hit on her in
the span that it takes to sh to watch a
vine. You liked that,
you liked that reference.
Trying to be hip to the DUBSTEP fucking
generation is dub step already over.
Have you moved onto something
else or Shabbat for,
for um,
that fucking look on your goddamn face.
Alright,
I could break you in half like a pencil.
Will you stop looking at me like you
can kick the shit out of me while you're
dancing? Maybe that's what it is.
Maybe that's just the funny stuff.
Just something funny about
it. Attitude, dancing. Um,
can you guys send me some clips to some
of the funniest attitude dancer you can
find?
So maybe put some together
right?
They go,
you know what I love is when you guys
take clips from my podcast and then you
play the audio underneath
like some of the, the, uh,
the animation that people have done is,
it's fucking so creative like that one.
When that guy did the one for,
and I sang that song,
do you know what it means
to Miss New Orleans?
That's where my baby goes.
And the guy did the whole animation
of it and I was talking about somebody
throwing up and when the
word throw up came in,
it looked like it was launched
out of somebody's mouth,
like at Arctic [inaudible]
really creative. So how bout uh,
as I'm talking about these people
dancing, just have, just put,
come on you guys. All you fucking
youngsters, you know how to use computers.
Just split the audio underneath
and just have that kind of dancing
over the top. Like that's
the video. I don't know how
to say technically. Anyways,
let's get back to this thing. So he,
all right. First thing you gotta do
is a I would you got to
drink your coffee there.
Does she come around?
Okay.
This is so hard. How do I give
you advice? All I can give you,
I can't tell you what to say because I
never know what to say until I'm there in
the moment and something pops in unless
she's really good looking. And then I,
at that age I would just get
fucking intimidating. It'd be like,
how's just going to sit here? And
you see he might bran muffin. Um,
when would you do,
I don't know if,
do you got something coming up but you
can invite it to, this is what I would do.
I would come there frequently enough that
she starts to recognize you. All right.
And then ease your way into kind of
no one or I guess I would do that.
And then you have something
if you've got a fucking,
whatever you kids do nowadays.
Okay.
You know,
if there's a big ecstasy shipment coming
to town and you're going to meet the
truck there with the glow sticks and he
got an extra pair of glow sticks that
you could hand to her.
Uh,
yeah.
Maybe you could do that
something where I'm just flailing here.
Don't, don't fucking ask me
coffee. Shot of what it did.
I never picked up any girl that
worked at a fucking coffee shop.
I was good on the subway in New York.
But that was because they would always
be some weirdo doing something weird and
then you could just lock in
with the other person, you know,
like look at this fucking maniac
and then you could make something,
say something funny about that.
You'd make them laugh and then you
were in that the gym coffee shops,
that's out of my wheelhouse.
So I would just say go there enough
where she starts to recognize you try to
extend the conversation each time you
order and then blah blah blah. But,
but the thing is you can't keep coming
in there cause you really going to look
like a creep. So I would say within
three visits, give yourself three visits.
Yeah,
on the third visit you just
got to fucking asker. You know,
if she's seen anybody and it
have something to invite her to,
that's going to be a fun thing.
Don't just be like,
oh he's willing to take y'all show time.
And maybe I could pull it out
and you could just look at it.
You don't have to touch it. Don't do
it like that. Have something to too.
Okay.
An event,
ladies like the events and I don't know
what they're into what your age, but um,
I dunno the first time it's too weird.
You got to have unreal
game that I don't have,
so I can't fucking give you advice.
Second time she's getting to know you
and the third time you go for it, right.
Swing for the fucking fence.
Just say, look, Cutie Pie.
I don't work here. All right.
So I know this is well,
what am I supposed to do? I'm attracted
to you. All right. Fuck Sakes.
Put Down the God damn coffee
and, and come to me to, to the,
to the burning man thing.
I got plenty of Sunscreen
and ecstasy and uh, you know,
and it's not a sex thing. I mean, I would
hope it would eventually turn into it,
but more in like a lovingly thing,
like the kind of thing where I wouldn't
tell my friends what we did because I
care for you kind of thing.
You know,
maybe we lay in the dirt and roll around
next to that thing that's on fire.
Right?
I have no coffee shop game. Hey,
anybody out there of coffee shop game?
I don't drink coffee. That's the
thing. All right, it's fucking gross.
It tastes like dirty water and it
burns my mouth so I don't fuck with it.
And that just takes all that coffee
shop pussy right out the fucking window.
They always just seem like the coffee
shop people to me always seemed like
hipsters, like they just were
over everything, you know?
So if you're over everything, you're over
everything. The fucking Grand Canyon,
you're over that.
My dumb ass is coming in there with the,
you're not going to be over that
lack of pigment a. All right.
The mall. Billie holiday. Very
nice. I am going on all a day.
I'm going to Italy. I'm going
to miss thanksgiving. Um,
what's your plan of attack
when you enter a mall?
Are you on a mission or
are you a window shopper?
Do you have a favorite gift you've ever
been given and what's your go to Mall
Food Panda Express. Taco Bell's sparrow
pizza. It's spiraled. Pizza sucks.
It always looks good, I'll tell
you. But it really fills you up.
I usually go with the chicken parm or
shown and that, that one a little scary.
Then I get on the plane and they start
farting into that fucking flotation
device beneath me. Or perhaps a
fancy sandwich from Obam Paul.
They don't have, there's
nothing fancy about that other
than the fucking name. Um,
all bond pan. If you're still living in
the 90s, always making fun of the place.
Thanks and gobble, gobble, go fuck
yourself. All right. My plan of attack.
When I enter a mall, I only go to a
mall when I need something, that's it.
And I know what I want and I know where
it is and I go in there and when it's
not there, I'm like, oh, what
the fuck? And then I leave. Um,
I do not window shop at malls.
I hate malls.
It's just all those fucking people and it,
it just makes me,
they're just depressing. When I was
younger, it was great. You walked around,
there was all these fucking,
I was like, what you did?
You go to the mall and then you ran into
girls that you were in your grade and
they'd be like, hi, Bill.
And I'd be like, hi.
And I'd walk away my face all red.
And then it was like, Whoa, why didn't
I say thought that I hate myself?
And then I went, when? Then where
would I sit down and eat? Um,
I don't like Panda Express. Uh, Taco Bell,
no fast food. Mexican food. Why
don't you just play Russian roulette?
That's Taco bell is Russian
roulette for your ass.
I'm spiral pizzas. Same fucking
thing. Where would, where would I go?
Well, if I had to choose smaller
as I go to, I'd go to sparrow. Um,
that's usually some barbecue thing.
I Dunno.
You know what I hate is when they had,
they'd have that little sweet and sour
chicken on the toothpicks and then that
overly smiling Asian women would come
over and ask you if you wanted one.
Yeah.
It's just like, didn't you like poison
the toys? I don't want to eat that. Right.
How Archie bunker was that I just don't
like, I just fucking creeps me out.
That you're walking around with food.
Like where,
where was that? Where did
you get that? You know,
you're on this side of the counter,
like on that side.
I already know there's enough health
code violations at sparrow pizza,
Taco Bell and Panda Express. Enough
rat turds in that shit that, you know,
I should run out of here right now.
But now you're on this side
where people are sneezing.
You're on this side of the sneeze
glass walking around with that shit.
You don't even have a covered stuck
with a little fucking toothpick.
And then you've got that other thing
over there where people stick their use
toothpicks. Well, you get that
fucking glazed chicken out of my face.
This smiley be it.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah. I'm too old to eat at those places.
When I was younger aid at Mickey D's, Oh,
ate McDonald's hose and Mcdonald's
guy a Kentucky fried chicken cold.
I can never eat it hot. That grease when
it's hot, it makes me sick to my stomach.
When it's cold, it's fucking ecstasy.
And I would melt into the rug,
into the rug like I was
on in train spotting. Um,
I'd like friendlies back in the day,
get myself a nice burger,
melt in a fucking Jim Dandy, nice.
3000 calories to the fucking hat.
And then I walk out of there and go play
Frisbee football because that's what
you did back then with my fucking
white sox yanked up to underneath,
underneath my Patella. Um, Ken Patella.
All right. That's the podcast
for this week. People, I
don't know what to tell you.
All right. I hope you guys
have a wonderful thanksgiving.
My European tour is about to start.
I'm going over to Italy and speaking
of going to like the first bowl ever,
I'm going to go to the coliseum.
So if you're in Italy and
you're going to be over there,
look for me in the coliseum.
Um,
it hasn't even hit me yet. Then
I'm going to be, I actually,
we landed Charles de Gaulle
airport in Paris and then we,
we fly over to Italy and
it's an unbelievable, it's
something to give thanks for,
it's an unbelievable privilege that,
um,
I could do what I do for a living and
enough people come out to see me that I
can take the lovely Nia with
me over to, uh, to Italy.
And so thank you to everybody who's come
out to my shows this year and all the
years past. Um, and uh,
I'm really looking forward to giving
everybody their money's worth over in
Europe because I plan on doing
this for the rest of my career, uh,
doing stand up and traveling
over to Europe and I'm
going to tour Australia next
year and Canada, the Canada
one's going down in March and a,
we're working on those dates right now
and I just planned to keep on expanding
it. I'm hoping to also do New Zealand
and a, I know there's a Gig in India.
I mean,
why the fuck wouldn't I go?
I want to go over them and
see what that's like, right.
Tokyo and all those places I plan on, you
know, you only go around fucking once.
And I really believe that when
you're dead, you don't go anywhere.
I think he just go in the fucking ground
and you make the soil rich for other
living things.
So
if you've got a comedy club, I'm fucking
going to try to hit it before I die.
Something. I want to see the Great Wall
of China. I want to see all of that shit.
Why the fuck wouldn't ya? I
want, you know, something.
Somebody came up to me from Saudi
Arabia and gave me some currency.
It was really fucking cool. It said 50.
I'm like, Dude, you give me 50 bucks.
He's like,
yeah,
it's like worth 15 over here
and I can still 15 bucks.
So, um, I'm really into all of that stuff.
So I'm hoping to do was see as much as
I can and I couldn't do it without you
guys coming out to my show.
So there you go.
There's a warm fuzzy ending me giving
thanks on the week of Thanksgiving and
that's the podcast for this
week. Go fuck yourselves. Um,
for people in Los Angeles,
if you haven't heard,
I'm doing a new years eve Gig at the
Wiltern theater with the entire Rosebowl
tailgates syndicate, myself, Joe Barton,
nick, Jason Law had an Andrew
Fabulous, we're all going to be a,
we're all going to be telling jokes that
night and it's going to be phenomenal.
And, uh, there's not
a lot of tickets left.
It's going to be a great fucking show.
Come on down,
bring in the new year with
us. Um, and that's it. Okay.
Now this is the official end.
Go fuck yourselves.
Have a great thanksgiving and I'll
talk to you next week from Italy.
I think I'll be in Italy. Maybe I'll be
in London at that point. I don't know.
All right, that's it. Fuck you.